Come on, Felix. You can do this. Remember your name. Felix.
Alright, I remember... I have the biggest mouse pad
My mouse pad [pause] is so large
Follow @JUSTIN_FARAJ on Instagram NOW
It works at Nintendo. I have the largest mouse pad ...
Just think about how big your mouse pad is, Felix.
Everyone is so impressed by the size of your ...[pause]... mouse pad
Look at that shit, dog. Dude, You're a talent. You're a beast! You're a lion!
*ROAR*
*RAWWRR*
Just think about how big your mouse pad is.
It's so big!
You had the largest mouse pad...
Oh, oh, whoa, whoa, whoa... Oh great
Oh, Fantastic...
I am out of mouse pad, so I'm just gonna drag myself this way.
Oh God my keyboard is in the way. Uhh that's fine...
That's fine, that's fine... err lets just redo that
*bop*
Cartoon Cyborg